the Joker is Batman's greatest villain
man one of the best bad guys in comic
book history he's willing to do anything
no matter how psychotic to convince
Batman that morality and order are just
fantasy
here are the most terrible things he's
done to make that point of all the
atrocities he's ever committed the Joker
is probably best known for paralyzing
Barbara Gordon the grisly act occurs in
Alan Moore and Brian Bolland infamous
graphic novel Batman The Killing Joke in
an effort to prove that everyone is only
one bad day away from being just like
him The Joker does his best and worse to
drive the Dark Knight's most trusted
ally Commissioner Jim Gordon to becoming
a blubbering heap of his former self so
how does he plan on destroying Batman's
best friend he simply knocks on Barbara
Gordon's door and when the
commissioner's daughter says hello The
Joker shoots her the bullet shatters her
spine leaving her paralyzed from the
waist down
and while Joker didn't know it at the
time putting an end to her
crime-fighting career as Batgirl
then adding insult to injury The Joker
takes photos of his truly horrific
violation projecting them onto screens
and forcing the Commissioner to look at
them while he puts him through a
carnival fun house that's been twisted
into a psychological torture chamber the
story is both hugely controversial and
genuinely disturbing and it's still
considered to be the worst thing he's
ever done over 30 years after it was
first published in the aftermath of The
Killing Joke it's easy to think that the
Gordon family had suffered enough in
December of 1999 however the Joker
decided to take another brutal shot at
his least-favorite law enforcing family
this time the target was Sarah Essen
Gordon who went from being Jim Gordon's
partner on the police force to the
commissioners second wife
despite Gordon's dedication to keeping
the peace in America's most crime-ridden
City he and Sarah are happy together
even through the worst of times until
the Clown Prince of Crime shows up
will they get a load of me in the finale
of the epic year-long Batman storyline
no man's land in which Gotham City was
devastated by an earthquake and left to
fend for itself with no support from the
outside the Joker enacted one of his
most terrifying plans he kidnapped every
baby that had been born in Gotham during
the year that the city was isolated off
the grid holding them captive in the
basement of the Gotham Police Department
Sara was the first to arrive on the
scene but she stumbled straight into the
madman's trap the Joker tosses a baby at
Sara and as she tries to catch the child
he shoots her in the head with his work
done the Joker dropped his weapon walked
outside and immediately surrendered to
police defined Jim Gordon to ditch his
by-the-book moral code and shoot him and
even Batman told Gordon that he wouldn't
stop him if he wanted to take the shot
instead the Commissioner settled for
unloading his handgun into the Joker's
kneecap prompting the villain to break
out and laughter at the fact that he
might never walk again just like Barbara
once Dick Grayson grew up and graduated
from the role of Robin into being a hero
on his own as Nightwing the job of
Batman's sidekick was taken over by
Jason ha
unlike Grayson however Jason was
portrayed as an edgier character than
his predecessor whose rough upbringing
in an orphanage had left him prone to
crossing lines that Batman never would
that came to a head in a death in the
family a storyline were Jason ditched
the Dark Knight and went looking for his
long-lost mother
unfortunately for Jason he found the
Joker who delighted in beating the boy
wonders head in with a crowbar and then
blowing up the body for good measure it
was the most brutal thing he'd ever done
in a comics up to that point and the
loss of Robin haunted Batman for years
to come you can't blame this one
entirely on the Joker though death in
the family had a gimmick allowing fans
to call in and vote on whether Jason
would live or die when the votes were
tallied it came out to five thousand two
hundred and seventy one voting for Robin
to live and 5343 calling for his death
with a margin of just 72 votes Jason was
toast and the Joker racked up his most
famous kill everyone remembers that
death in the family for the scene when
the Joker beats Robin to death with a
crowbar and for good reason still it's
kind of weird that nobody really talks
about how the first part of that story
is all about the Clown Prince of Crime
selling nuclear weapons to terrorists
because his previous high score
according to plan do I really look like
a guy with a plan obviously this had
less of an impact on the comics than the
whole killing Batman's sidekick thing
but come on we all have to agree that
arms deals with terrorists are pretty
bad in general rights even stranger it
only happened because he was in
desperate need of cash since he had a
spare cruise missile complete with a
nuclear warhead laying around he decided
to use it for a quick buck fortunately
the terrorists never got the new to Tel
Aviv as planned
although Batman didn't stop them it
turns out that the Joker isn't that
great at nuclear engineering and after
taking the missile apart to smuggle it
into the Middle East he didn't put it
back together correctly it ended up
exploding in the truck when they tried
to launch it without detonating the
nuclear warhead while it doesn't get the
press of some other well-known Joker
story's soft targets is one of the
absolute best and features a truly
sinister plot it originally ran in 2003
in the pages of Gotham central a book
that focused on the Gotham City Police
Department and the way ordinary people
tried to deal with being cops in a city
dominated by superheroes and villains
it showed a grittier side of Gotham
without sacrificing the idea of a world
full of superpowers and became a fan
favorite thanks to its relatable
characters and their very realistic
reactions as you might expect when the
Joker showed up those reactions
basically amounted to sheer terror it
started off with a literal bang a sniper
took out Gotham City's mayor with a
headshot sparking a series of apparently
random killings that terrorized the city
in the weeks before Christmas even
live-streaming a countdown of his
potential targets eventually the police
discovered that it was the Batman's arch
nemesis pulling the trigger but things
took a strange turn
even by Gotham City standards when the
Joker walked up to the police station
three days before Christmas and allowed
himself to be arrested then came the
twist it turned out that the whole thing
the assassination of the mayor the
random killings the live stream sniper
attacks was just a setup for an even
deadlier punchline with the Joker in
custody the people who had been scared
off the streets by the sniper attacks
scrambled to get their holiday shopping
done which is exactly what the Joker
wanted he set bombs in the stock room of
the city's biggest toy store with plans
of explosively ruining Christmas for
Gotham's kids
fortunately the GCPD
evacuated the civilians and when the
Joker broke free of the interrogation
room he managed to rack up a few more
gleeful kills before he was stopped
the animated series Batman Beyond was
set decades in the future
after Bruce Wayne retired and eventually
handed the Batman identity down to cool
young future teen Terry McGinnis with a
few exceptions
Terry's adventures avoided using
established Batman villains instead
giving him his own roster of foes that
seemed inspired by spider-man's classic
rogues gallery that makes sense though
since Terry himself felt like the answer
to the question what if Peter Parker
became Batman instead when Joker came
back though he came back hard and
brought two incredibly disturbing
reveals with him the first was that
before dying the Joker had implanted his
own consciousness into the second Robin
Tim Drake so that he could take over his
body and re-emerge years later to
continue terrorizing Gotham after death
the other more disturbing reveal was how
he pulled it off thirty five years
earlier he and Harley Quinn had
kidnapped timp holding him for weeks
before Batman tracked him down the Joker
and Harley spent that time torturing
Robin breaking him mentally and
transforming him physically into Joker
jr. complete with the chalk white skin
and permanently fixed grin
he's lost Batman Robin his mind the last
sound you hear will be our laughter when
the Joker showed off his handiwork to
Batman and tried to force his new son to
kill the hero
Tim managed to break free just long
enough to shoot the Joker instead
killing him the image of Tim's maniacal
laughter turning the sobs with tears
streaming down his disfigured face is
probably the most disturbing thing to
ever hit DC's animated properties so
much so in fact that the scene was
heavily edited for its original release
giving the Joker a very different death
scene and eliminating the more explicit
references to torture the uncut version
has been available since 2003 however
just in case you want to see how dark
those cartoons can get when DC
relaunched their line in 2011 as the new
52 the first thing the Joker did was
arrange to have his own face cut off by
a villain called the doll maker so that
he could leave it hanging in his cell at
Arkham when he escaped that might be the
single weirdest thing he's ever done but
it wasn't the worst when he returned a
few years later to cut everyone else's
face off though that definitely made the
at the climax of the death of the family
story arc not to be confused with death
in the family
Batman was put through a gauntlet of
villains as he made his way through
Arkham in the end he was overwhelmed and
captured waking up at a long dinner
table to find the Joker waiting for him
of course The Dark Knight isn't the only
guest at this particular party The Joker
has also invited back droll along with
the current and former Robins tied up
with their faces heavily bandaged in
front of each victim there's a serving
platter covered with a sterling silver
dump and in a ghoulish twist out comes
Alfred with a grin stretched from ear to
ear no doubt caused by the Joker's
infamous toxin when Alfred then lifts
the domes from each plate the Batman
family members finally see the evenings
gruesome meal their own faces looking
back at them thankfully after batman
escapes his confinement he unwraps the
bandages from his family and realizes
it's all been one sick joke everyone's
faces are fine the Joker just wanted to
have a little sadistic fun it does leave
us with the question though if those
weren't the Batman family's faces whose
were they well he's usually found in and
around Gotham City the Joker
occasionally shows up in some pretty
unexpected places
the nine part Emperor Joker's storyline
for example happened in the Superman
comics and involved one of the most
terrifying premises any comic book
reader could imagine in that story
Superman's old foe mister mixes pit lake
the magical fifth dimensional M who uses
his reality-warping powers to mess with
Superman every few months decides to see
what would happen if he handed off those
powers to another trickster to find out
he gives the Joker just 1% of his magic
that would be bad enough but the Joker
manages to trick MIT Xia's picnic into
giving him the other 99% to go along
with it with these incredible powers he
entertains himself by remaking the world
in his own twisted image as you might
expect he spends a lot of time on Batman
torturing the Dark Knight to death every
night and then resurrecting him every
morning to do it again which traumatized
his Batman to the point where Superman
erases his memories to keep him saying
his most disturbing act though eating
the entire population of China yes
really he eats every single person in
China and in true Joker style he uses a
pair of chopsticks there's a sixth sense
of humor and then there's absolute -
Brava
if you ever wanted to see the Joker at
his scariest do yourself a favor and
pick up a copy of the Batman adventures
number three from 1992 because there's a
sequence in that issue that's still
terrifying all these years later as he
so frequently does the Joker takes over
Gotham City's airwaves with his own
broadcast his guest is Jim Gordon
kidnapped and tied up in front of the
cameras while the Joker offers a
monologue that a full 16 years before
the Dark Knight is devoted to the idea
that law and order are false ideas and
that the only thing that truly exists is
random destructive chaos upset the
established order and everything becomes
I'm an agent of chaos to illustrate his
point he punctuates his speech by
picking up a baseball bats and breaking
Gordon's arms while the horrified
citizens of Gotham and Batman watch it's
pretty grim stuff but here's the best
and worst part the Batman adventures was
the tie-in book set in the universe of
Batman the Animated Series and his
mature and forward-thinking as that show
was it was still a cartoon for children
this was a comic aimed at younger
readers that featured the Joker
announcing that in a world that was just
he wouldn't be able to just pick up a
bat and start beating on a beloved
heroic Police Commissioner and then
proved himself correct by doing just
that that's a weird thing to learn when
you're still trying to get a handle on
subtraction since being introduced on
Batman the Animated Series Harley Quinn
has made the leap to comics movies and
more to become one of DC's most popular
characters a big part of that popularity
comes down to the idea that for a
villain she's always been incredibly
sympathetic
she's a participant in Joker's madness
and mayhem but ultimately he's the one
pulling the strings manipulating and
abusing her into going along with it
considering all that he's done to her
over the years it's easy argue that
their entire relationship he counted as
a whole among the worst things that
Joker has ever done but there's a
singular example in the pages of Mad
Love the graphic novel that gave us
Harley's origin when she takes it upon
herself to capture Batman and improve
one of his discarded death trap jokes
The Joker flies into a rage he backhands
her while ranting about how she doesn't
get the joke then knocks her through a
window to a five-story fall she survives
of course but only through chance and
only to find herself going back to him
in
and the story was adapted for Batman the
Animated Series in 1999 but it would be
another decade before readers would get
to see Harley breaking away from the
Joker on the page and the screen the
Joker has been undeniably successful in
the world that thematic villainy and
pretty much anything he's done for the
past couple of decades has been more
like gilding and increasingly deadly
Lily
he's already Batman's arch nemesis he's
already the deadliest and most feared
criminal in DC's considerable roster
were bad guys and if you think a
villainy as being like a sports Ben
there's really nothing else to do as a
result you might think that if and when
the Joker finally died he'd be able to
look back on his life tally up the final
body count and be satisfied that his
work was finally done you'd be wrong not
only has the Joker managed to ensure
that his reign of terror will continue
past his own death he's done it in a
truly bizarre way he booby-trapped his
own heart according to Batman himself
the Joker somehow laced his
cardiovascular system with a singular
super toxin that will be released at the
moment of his death attorney whoever
finally gives any kills him his
preference of course being Batman into
an all-new all deadly Joker he even once
shot himself to dos Batman but
fortunately the Dark Knight managed to
hold off the transformation long enough
to work up a cure that is some buckwild
comic-book science and some pretty
advanced biochemistry for a dude whose
major interest include purple suits and
mayhem but it's also a pretty scary
tactic not only will he be inflicting
his own madness on someone else but
he'll be ensuring that it continues
indefinitely ruining countless more
lives at the cost of his own of course
that only happens if he dies but you
know things have gotten pretty bad when
the Joker staying alive to keep on doing
what he does is actually the best option
The Joker's most heinous crime might not
be any of the ones that have happened in
the comics or even the movies instead
it's part of the backstory of a video
game in 2013 the Joker showed up in
injustice gods among us a fighting game
created by NetherRealm Studios the
developers of Mortal Kombat perhaps
surprisingly this video game has a
backstory that was compelling enough to
be the source material for a comic that
ran for a full 5 years to justify the
setup of a world where the superheroes
were slugging it out to the death the
game took place in an alternate universe
where Joker pushed Superman well beyond
the breaking point first he steals
nuclear submarine then he somehow
manages to poison the Man of Steel with
Scarecrow's fear toxin the poison cloud
Superman's mind and makes him think he's
fighting doomsday the unstoppable
monster that once nearly killed him in
reality he was really unleashing his
entire strength on a target that the
Joker chose for him instead Lois Lane
even worse she was pregnant with
Superman's child as Lois dies the launch
of a nuclear missile wipes metropolis
off the map leaving Superman's entire
life devastated first Krypton
now metropolis people you love tend to
blow up don't they as a result Superman
snaps shoving his fist through the
Joker's chest of all the stories where
Superman goes bad and there are plenty
of them injustice goes to the darkest
place that the Man of Steel has ever
been it gives us a world where the Joker
won proving that anybody even Superman
is capable of breaking their own rules
it pushed far enough check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
villains are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]